so Bell solution was to take two pairs
and twist them around each other which
is very smart okay but like I said it's
got problems especially as you go over
longer distances this is what Rick you
are saying okay that our little bit of
interference that can come in over a
long distance it's really going to add
up okay so people decide this stuff this
is called coaxial cable coaxial cable is
where once a lot of time
you should have dial-up internet or you
used to have cable internet mail iPod on
dial-up internet it still comes through
cables right well the cable of cable
internet is coaxial cable so let me try
to explain this okay here's a diagram
once though it's not a diagram it's a
photo okay you can see it's quite on a
small scale okay and you've got these
four different elements okay so let me
go through each one what you've got in
the middle is just a single copper wire
a single copper wire okay so if you like
I'm going to cut it across ways and I'm
going to look at it side on so this is a
cross-section so please do this
okay what are we looking at now just
before I am I give you any more details
apart from the fact that you've got this
single copper wire in here I should say
it's single that's important why is this
called coaxial cable what do you think
is the word that's underneath sorry
start again
what does KO mean when you put ko on the
front of a word what does that mean like
coordinates or coordination or together
right so things that are doing the same
thing right when you've got current in
front of axial what do you think is the
axial is a is an adjective
what do you think is that now on
underneath axial axis right so the idea
here is all of these different layers
there's this four okay they all share
the same axis of symmetry okay as
opposed to this twisted pair these have
opposite um axes right but coaxial cable
everything's on the one axis so that's
why it's called coaxial okay so what are
the things that are sharing in acts as
well number one you know this couple lap
number two you've got this insulating
here it's usually plastic okay then what
you got is actually and if you can you
know see it make it out on the photo
what's this part here this is metal why
don't they put metal there it's not to
trade those signals what's that metal
for yeah
good again we're trying to cancel out
things coming from the outside okay so
they call that they call that part a
metal sheath okay so again it's trying
to cancer the electromagnetic
interference in the same way that a
second cable would but it does a much
better job okay lastly you just have a
wrap up for this so you can you know
hold it with your hand and you're not
going to be caught in the middle okay so
this stuff is a lot more expensive okay
because for every coaxial cable you've
just got one signal whereas for twisted
pair you've got double right and also
all the extra layers and that kind of
thing particularly this metal sheath
they're quite expensive to produce
okay so coaxial cable is more costly but
it can go much further and you can send
more data through it more reliably
that's why cable internet is so much
faster than dial-up okay because you can
send through things here and know that
over a long distance there's going to be
less interference okay